a guy run onto the tennis court and lit  his arm on fire during a Roger Federer  thing and it was a climate activist who  he who he described as a as a climate uh  narcissist right and he said that's  what's going on that's if if you're a  person who who glues their hand to the  wall after throwing tomato soup on a  Priceless work of art  um it doesn't it doesn't matter  why you did it or what your conscious  explanation is for doing it what you  really want is to be looked at  you want to be seen and that's  unfortunately how we reward those people  you're not on a tennis court and light  your arm on fire you want to be seen and  then you'll talk about whatever the  cause of the day is